hey G of your ticket well yeah I went
over that this morning i was at Showtime
so i think i have my ticket oh you got
your ticket are you gonna resell it for
something like c700 yeah no Alex I was
there at the beginning and trying to
make this fight i'll be there ringside
believe me so put into perspective
though what why this is happening and
what this kind of does to inflate the
price of a ticket in sixty seven
thousand dollars i mean the face value
will be about 10 it may go up beyond
67,000 um well you know when you get
into the second market or something
because basically you don't have many on
sale to the public you've got not only
the MGM but you have the two networks
and you have the two promotional
companies top-ranked and Mayweather
product promotions also scooping up all
the tickets so so really you know every
celeb you can think of is contacted all
the networks and everyone else sorry I
just probably loaded another couple
hundred celebs on Showtime but but
that's how it's being distributed pretty
much is this unusual to create me when I
heard this story I was like this is a
futures market I mean is this unusual
for this kind of speculative futures
market where I'm promising hey if you
I'll give you a hundred thousand I'll
give you tour of that well first of all
you better get your hands on the tickets
I mean there have been situations at
Super Bowls and elsewhere where
companies have gone on and said I'll get
you two tickets can cost you 100 people
fly to the venue and suddenly they have
no ticket so hopefully that won't happen
out in Las Vegas but but beyond that the
money is staggering in this fight you
know I was involved in boxing for the
last 35 years the numbers are out of
control the foreign rights numbers the
site numbers as we just discussed but
the television revenue the pay-per-view
numbers will be astronomical I was gonna
say what does this mean for HBO and
Showtime I mean quantify it well you
know it's a huge windfall for the
promotion the bulk of the money goes
directly to the fighters thankfully in
this sport which is a wonderful thing I
mean you know Floyd Mayweather could
make anywhere from a hundred to 180
million dollars that night yeah now I'm
dropped literally yeah sorry about that
but but that is
no that is what he deserves if he's
generating that kind of revenue why
shouldn't he walk away with the majority
of the money what do you want to see
when well I lived with Floyd for many
years i'm biased because i'm working for
showtime for God's sakes on all these
preview shows so so Floyd has been great
to me and we're very close and I've been
there since the beginning I had a
relationship with Manny when I was at
HBO too but but my heart and soul has to
be with Floyd mate all right Ross going
to florida and he's not selling his
ticket